nostalgia is a powerful force able to
work people's perceptions so you know
what they say you can't go home again
something that anybody who's tried to
watch the favorite childhood shows is
what adults can confirm sometimes it's
best to just leave well enough alone and
not revisit the past as proven by these
TV shows that have become unwatchable
with age
full house if you were like most kids in
the late 80s you were probably parked in
for an ABCs family-friendly TGIF walk
every Friday night
and your parents probably hated every
second of it because full house is
saccharine morality and terrible puns or
just flat-out hard to stomach remember
that sausage and lima bean casserole m8
I called it my Sunday surprise we called
it our Monday surprise I was still
getting surprised on Tuesday a hundred
terrible catchphrase later you gotta
speed we're reminded just how awkward
and unfunny the original show was
especially now that the series
continuation polar House has gotten past
the first season on Netflix have mercy
Xena Warrior Princess Xena Warrior
Princess is mainly remembered for the
way it challenged female stereotypes and
the discussions that raged over its
lesbian subtext and it also gave the
world Lucy Lawless
for which we offer our heartfelt thanks
however the importance of the show is
kind of papered over the fact that it's
not actually very good with any
production values and clumsy directors
not to mention random tonal shifts like
hyper-violent suddenly giving way to
musical numbers will always love Xena
the cultural phenomenon but to show
itself not so much Highlander the series
20 years ago Highlander the series was
about as good as it got for high-fantasy
now we have Game of Thrones and once
you've seen that or any other modern
television epic it's hard to go back to
Highlanders outdated special-effects
repetitive immortal of the month script
and OneNote act the show kept telling us
there could only be one well this ain't
it Saved by the Bell
while ninety spin-off Saved by the Bell
to college years and Saved by the Bell
the new class has always been pretty
unwatchable the original show was once
considered essential television digging
out the NBC
high school sitcom for your kids to
watch today isn't it viable however as
many of the lessons are painfully dated
haven't you ever heard of the women's
movement well sure put on something cute
and move it into the kitchen you want
your kids to experience cool high school
entertainment just buy them some Archie
comics and spare them this horribly out
of touch television Walker Texas Ranger
the fact that Chef Norris has become a
living parody of this character is
almost but not quite enough to prepare
you for a return visit to be
unapologetically manly Walker Texas
Ranger
well Norris clearly a skilled martial
artist he struggled pretty much
everything else after them here and he's
not the only one and how you do a little
Bubba fine and it's a little visitor now
I don't want you always how you say it
in Cherokee oh pardon my french but I'll
begin Walker told me at ease how bad is
Walker Texas Ranger one of Conan
O'Brien's most beloved comedy routines
is simply playing clips from the show
that about says it all my Walker Texas
Ranger lever right here let's give it a
shot and see how it works let me go they
watch at its height Baywatch was one of
America's most highly coveted exports
commanding over a billion weekly viewers
for more than one hundred and
forty-eight countries looking back at
the show today it's plain to see that
the skin routinely on display was
literally the only appeal with nowhere
near enough drama to warrant an
hour-long slot they watch those the gaps
with copious amounts of running normally
presented in slow motion to not only
capture the females bouncing chests and
all their glory but to make up for the
fact that there isn't much else going on
critics at the time I hate it it may
have taken nearly two decades the fans
are finally catching up thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you